it was a picture of Republican chaos for
the first time in a century members had
to vote for the speaker of the U.S House
of Representatives more than once and
still after three times failed to
produce a winner a speaker has not been
elected
a group of dissatisfied right-wing
Republicans in the House Freedom caucus
had a list of Demands easy removal of
the speaker Prime committee assignments
and fiscal conservatism and to highlight
them they banded together to block
would-be house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
Mike the day began as it has every two
years for 200 years there were
nominations I rise today to nominate the
gentleman from California Kevin McCarthy
Hakeem Jeffries of New York
there were votes McCarthy Jeffries
McCarthy Jeffries but even with the
votes counted no one won again
and again
and again
inside the Capitol and at the White
House Democrats including President
Biden watched the embarrassment of their
political Rivals he's just not going to
insert himself he's going to let the
process play out
and continue to do the work of the
American people
and they cheered Democrat Hakeem
Jeffries The Honorable Hakeem Jeffries
of the state of New York has received
212.
who came out on top in all three ballots
but not with the majority needed to win
the speakership the voting has a long
way to go to beat the record in 1856 the
house picked a speaker after 133 ballots
in two months the newspeaker will have a
razor-thin majority and little ability
to pass legislation with a Democratic
Senate and a Democratic president
as McCarthy and his allies regroup in
hopes of winning another day the rebels
marked the day as a victory and proof of
their power in a clearly divided party
John hendren Al Jazeera Capitol Hill